- I feel like...
Hmm.
With like, anybody in my life,
I have a lot of intention
with them and they...
Like, I know I add to
theirs and they add to mine
and I don't believe in just like,
being in a romantic
relationship just to be in one.
And yeah.
And I think admittedly, I
am like commitment-phobic,
and I also prefer like...
I don't know, it's like
something I say a lot,
but I prefer like short-term relationships
more than long-term.
Like, I love when
relationships have an end date
and I know that's not a popular opinion.
And I think also, having an end date
is like reassuring to me
'cause it's like then you can
make the most of each other
and cherish each other until the end date.
But yeah, I also think like
I just haven't met someone
that I want past the end date.
Yeah.
(speaker laughing)
- I'm single because it's
just like the context
in which I meet a lot of people,
and especially in this day and age,
it's very difficult to find someone
that just like doesn't vape
or just doesn't smoke weed,
and isn't like huge into
drinking a lot of alcohol, right?
It's just, I don't know, it gets tiring.
Not finding like normal people
who just wanna go outside
and not go on walks because, I don't know,
maybe it's also about how
it's hard to meet new people.
So, I don't know.
That's mostly about it.
- I don't feel like I put
myself out there a lot.
Lack of confidence too,
sometimes, you know?
Like, when I was, a
couple of years ago maybe,
I was a bit heavier, on the heavier side.
It always like weighed on my mind like,
oh, I'm not attractive enough.
I just couldn't like shake
that kind of mental fortitude off of me.
I would get bullied for my looks
by other people of my race,
which really hurt me a lot.
'cause like I can get it from
like people not of my race,
but like, girls from my
own race saying that,
it like hurt me a lot,
'cause to me it was like,
if they didn't find me
attractive, who will?
Even though like now,
I don't think I'm like that bad-looking.
I think I'm kind of nice, I won't lie,
but yeah, just that only
happened like recently,
maybe like a couple years ago
that I started to get
confidence in myself.
- [Thoraya] Wait, say that again.
Say that again.
- It's kinda like a filter, right?
Like, people that are six foot and above,
the girls that they date,
they have to constantly wonder,
are they with me just 'cause of my height
or just 'cause of my looks?
Are they with me because they like me?
For example, like that one girl that said,
"If you were taller I'd date you."
I mean, that just means that
you have a great personality
and somebody else might see that
and not care about your height.
So that's fine.
- [Thoraya] There you go.
That's a real friend right there.
- I hate this guy.
- I am still single
because I find it very hard
to like jump out of a relationship
and then find somebody new.
It's very, I don't know, different.
Yeah.
- [Thoraya] So you're
recently single then.
- Like, seven months.
So I don't know how recent that is for,
you know, most people.
We were just talking about this too.
It's because like that one
person makes you open up
to do new things that you like never knew
you were capable of.
And then now that they're gone,
it's like you don't wanna do that
with somebody new type of thing.
So, yeah.
- [Thoraya] You're still loyal to that...
- Yeah.
I feel like no matter how much he hurt me
and all this and that,
I feel like I still have
like such a soft spot
for that person and like, who knows,
maybe they were the person,
but at least not for now.
Yeah.
- So I'm like fresh out of
a five year relationship.
I'm like, been single for
like three months now,
and I'm single because I feel like
when you truly love someone
and you have something special,
for me it's like you need to
be a certain level of degree
and invested in it and
invested in the future.
For me, I was one foot in, one foot out,
trying to get both foot in,
sometimes trying to get both feet out
and it just wasn't what that person
or the relationship deserved.
And so it felt like the right thing to...
The hardest thing but the right thing,
it was almost like the right mistake.
- Why am I single?
I have bad taste in men
and that usually doesn't end well for me.
So I just haven't found
anyone that meets all the...
Like, checks all the boxes.
- I'm single because people
here are kind of (bleep).
- I'm still single because
people are full of (bleep).
- Because a lot of
people are (bleep) stupid
and I just have no
patience for it anymore.
- [Thoraya] Why are you single?
- That's a good question.
- Oh, I just broke up my ex last month.
- I am single because I
just went through a breakup.
- And her therapist told her to be single.
Her therapist told her
that she should be single.
- Because my parents are obscenely strict.
- 'Cause I can't date.
- I don't really care about
being in relationships.
- I am single because I am asexual
and just don't really like
being in relationships.
- I believe that God is
waiting for the correct time
to put that person in my life.
- Because I like, always
become friends with guys.
I'm like the advice one.
Like I give them all
their relationship advice.
- Everyone that I've liked is far away.
So I'm single and keeping in touch.
- I'm single because no
one ever likes me back.
No one likes me.
Yeah.
I kind of like don't ever
wanna be in a relationship.
Like, I don't wanna get married.
- [Thoraya] So it goes both ways.
It seems like you also just don't want...
- Yeah.
- [Thoraya] Okay.
Why don't you ever wanna get married?
- Mm, I kind of just wanna be single
and like vibe on my own.
- I don't really have a reason for it.
I don't really care about being like...
It's not something I really worry about
just because like I was
raised to have high standards
and so if someone doesn't
meet that standard,
like my brain just doesn't
connect to the fact
that I have to like them.
I'm like, okay, nevermind.
Like, not in like an annoying way,
but especially if a guy likes another girl
or is talking to another girl,
like my brain just goes
like, okay, keep him.
Like, you can have him.
Because I think I just value
like the women in my life more,
even if it's like a stranger.
This woman, I feel like she has so much...
She has so much in her
and like if she wants him
then you can have him.
It's okay, I really don't mind.
I'm not gonna fight you over it.
Like I can't connect
the fact that I have to
care about a guy enough to
like be fighting over him.
Like, I'm so sorry.
Like, like unless like
it's like my best friend
in the entire world and
I'm gonna marry this guy.
Other than that like, I'm
not gonna fight for you.
Like, I'm so sorry.
Like, this is not who I am.
- Personally. I just don't think
I'm at a place in my life where...
I'm happy with where I'm at.
And so I like to...
I wanna be the person I can
be when I'm with someone,
if that makes sense.
Instead of like a lesser
version of what I want to be.
- [Speaker] What made you
come to that realization?
- Actually one of my ex-girlfriends,
'cause when I was with
her I tried really hard
to be better 'cause I didn't see myself
having a bright future.
And so, being with her, I
wanted to just be better
in every aspect of my life.
I don't know, like...
- I'd say I'm single
'cause I'm not really good
at catching feelings.
I just kind of don't get
like that emotionally.
I was never really like in
the mood for a relationship.
So I just like kind of like
shut that part off in my head.
So I would just never really like
catch feelings for someone.
I don't really...
Yeah, like I wish I do,
'cause it'd be nice to be
in a relationship sometimes
and have someone like
always there for you.
- I'm Diamond in "League of Legends."
- [Thoraya] Can you give people context
who don't know what that means?
- It's like a video game online.
It's like an online video game
and I'm really good at
it and like, you know,
it just kind of goes with
it, you know what I mean?
- [Speaker] And so why does
that mean that you're single?
- Well, you know, I spend all my time
on "League of Legends".
All my time and money.
I just don't like...
And I'm also really bad at
talking to women, you know?
- [Thoraya] Do you ever like wish that
you spent less time playing the game?
- No.
- [Thoraya] No.
- Yeah, I love "League of Legends", man.
I play it every day.
- Well, my parents would
say, "You're way too young."
You know, "You don't have time for that."
And you know, partly they're right.
I think that I am
emotionally mature enough
to maybe be in a relationship,
but I don't think I'm
emotionally mature enough
to take the ending of a
relationship right now.
'Cause I recently like went through
like a lot of friendship heartbreak
and I think that like
a romantic heartbreak
would send me into a psychotic break.
I think it would totally break me.
- [Friend] She's such wife material.
- [Thoraya] Wait, say that again guys.
- She's such wifey material.
She really is.
- She is.
She like treats us so right.
Like, I could be her girlfriend
and I'd be very happy with my life.
She cooks, she opens doors for us.
- She plans.
- She plans entire trips.
- She plans this whole thing.
- We don't live in San Diego,
she planned the entire trip.
- [Friend] Wife material.
- [Thoraya] How do you feel
hearing all your friends
say that about you?
- Blessed.
I love my friends.
I'd do anything for them.
- I think before, I used
to like look for that,
like, oh, like what can I do
to get a guy to like notice me
or like tell me I'm
pretty or I don't know.
And then when you like actually get that
or like you're in a
relationship for a while,
it's like, well what
was so good about that?
They're just saying I look pretty.
Like, what else though?
Like, you know what I mean?
Obviously, if I find someone
that is gonna treat me
kind, respectful, is cute, like...
Someone that I think is
really caring, like loves God,
like, that's very important to me.
And I think that that's
kind of hard to find,
especially with men.
Like every woman in this place,
like they probably are so amazing.
Like have something cute
and small about them
that's like unique or whatever.
And I don't know if I could say
the same thing about like, guys.
(all laughing)
I'm just being honest.
I'm not trying to be like...
I'm not saying guys are all bad
and oh they don't have
anything interesting.
I just mean like, I think
that there's something
so beautiful in each woman that I've seen.
Old women, like, it's so upsetting,
like, why are we afraid to get old?
I looked at, you know, the old
filter or whatever on TikTok.
I did that and I look
exactly like my Teta.
That's grandma in Arabic.
I was so happy.
I like started crying.
I was like, oh my gosh,
I'm gonna look so cute.
Like, and I think that's good.
We should really love ourselves.
I'm so tired of it.
I was tired of myself being sad.
Like, who cares, honestly.
Care about your grades, your career,
what are you gonna do
to help other people?
But don't let it like take
away from loving yourself.
So yeah.
- Hi everyone.
Thank you for watching.
I'll be posting bonus footage
from this episode on my Patreon.
That means more answers and
extended cuts of each answer.
And if you wanna see it, you can sign up.
I'll have it linked in my description,
and if I ever do follow-ups on the people
you see in this episode,
that'll be on my Patreon as well.
Thank you guys for watching.
I love you all and I'll see you next time.